arizona attorney general candidate lacey
cooper is a former border security
section chief for the u.s attorney's
office she joins us now to react good
morning lacey
good morning so is there a specific
reason that they're coming across
unaccompanied what's the story behind
this why are these kids coming here
unaccompanied
well listen there's a story behind each
of those children and not everyone comes
here for the same reason but i i do want
to point out that you know unaccompanied
minor does not mean an orphan i think
sometimes we hear that phrase and we
think that they don't have a parent back
home but a lot of these kids are sent by
their parents to the border to cross
without a legal guardian with them and
sometimes the parent is stuck on the
mexican side and they send their kid
through because they think that their
kid can get access to the united states
easier than they can so these are not
orphaned children that are living on the
streets they're children whose uh
parents or guardians have decided that
the circumstances warrant them sending
them uh through terrible circumstances
absolutely terrible circumstances to get
here to the border you know if these
kids come across the border
unaccompanied like that and you have a
chance to find one of their parents here
in the states are they
subject to prosecution for abandoning
their child is there is there anything
in our legal system that would deter
if they do have say a parent here that
would punish them and deter them from
allowing their child to go on this
dangerous journey
no if the parent is here with a lawful
status here and they request that their
kid be brought here then they're not
charged with any sort of child
abandonment but i tell you there should
be some criminal prosecution for the
smugglers and the cartels who bring the
kids here you know cartels make terrible
babysitters and that's exactly what
they're tasked to do when they bring a
kid here without any parent or guardian
to take care of them then the cartels
are in charge and we know that children
suffer abuses sexual abuses and physical
abuses along the way when they're just
put in the hands of these terrible bad
actors
you're looking to you're running for
arizona attorney general
obviously there are laws available to
you state laws what do you think you can
do as attorney general to help at least
arizona with the border problem
yeah absolutely the arizona law
allows for the prosecution of the drug
crimes at the border we know that the
movement of drugs and humans are done in
concert by the cartels so the ag can
definitely focus on the drug prosecution
side of the house and take down the
cartels and you know human trafficking
is huge some of these folks that are
being brought across the border
including children are brought here for
sex trafficking and labor trafficking
not just because they want to make a
better life here it's terrible what's
happening at the border and the attorney
general can weigh in by helping to
prosecute a lot of the crimes that are
happening in concert with the movement
of humans
lacey cooper candid for arizona attorney
general thank you so much for joining us
and good luck
thank you
all right still ahead it's not just
hispanic voters who are turning out on
the democratic
who are turning on the democratic party
while more asian americans are ditching
the left ahead of the midterm subscribe
to the fox news youtube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from tucker carlson tonight